[Captions by Y Translator]
Today ballpoint pens
are extremely common.
They are the most used
writing implement in the world,
with millions of them
manufactured every day.
Today, we are going to see
what happens
if we take the ink
out of 1,000 of them.
A thousand pens
is a whole lot
but each pen only
has a little bit of ink in it.
Amazingly that little bit
of ink is enough
to write for quite a while,
but we want to do some tests
with a lot of ink at once.
So we've got 1,000 pens
and we are going to take the ink
out of all of them.
The plan here
is pretty simple.
We're going to drain the ink
out of 1,000 ballpoint pens.
Collect it all in a cup and then
subject it to a number of tests,
heat, cold and vacuum.
I did a fair amount of
experimenting to figure out
what the best way
to get the ink out was.
I tried rollers.
I tried just letting
it drain out.
I tried several different things
and in the end what I found was that
this metal rod that
is almost the exact diameter
as the inside of the pens
does a pretty good job
of pushing the ink out.
Of course, there is
still a little bit left
on the sides of the tube.
It's not a perfect squeegee,
but there you can see
about the ink contents
of one single pen.
It's not more than
a few drops.
But when we take enough ink
out of enough pens,
I think we'll have
quite a bit.
That's it.
Last one.
That's a lot of pens.
According to mix website,
each pen has enough ink
to draw approximately two
and a half kilometers.
That means with all 1000
of these pens,
there should have been
enough ink to draw a line from
Los Angeles, California
to Lafayette, Louisiana.
Oh man, there's
pens everywhere.
Who did this?
Look at that.
That is a big old cup full
of ballpoint pen ink
and this other cup
that has just a tiny bit.
We started in this cup
and I was like,
oh we might run out of space
and so I moved on to this cup.
Thinking we might need
to move on even from that
but it did all fit in here.
So we've just got tiny bits
in here and a whole lot in here.
I want to just look at it like,
this is interesting stuff.
So it's not thin,
it's not like India ink
or just ballpoint pen ink,
this stuff is super thick
like corn syrup.
This here is black ink,
but it's not perfectly black either.
There's just this little bit
of a metallic sheen to it.
I don't really know
what color it looks like,
sort of a ridiculously
dark pinkish purple color,
but it really does look like
a black metal sort of thing.
It is of course a little tricky
to get something so dark
to show up on camera well,
but we'll try and get some
good lighting on it so it's visible.
It's really dark
and it's really reflective,
both hard to film.
[music playing]
We've got this smaller cup
of ink that we poured out
and we want to see
what happens
if we throw this
in a vacuum chamber.
You're probably curious.
I know I'm curious.
Let's see what it does.
See bubbles forming.
Now I'm seeing lots
of bubbles forming.
And now it's expanding
very rapidly.
Holy cow.
[laughter]
I let back in
the tiniest amount of air
and just all of those bubbles
disappeared.
I think that means
that this ink
bubbles really,
really easily.
All right,
that looks awesome.
Oh, and it broke.
I'm not letting any pressure
back in now and
and it's--
it's not bubbling up
over the top anymore.
It's bubbling a lot.
Today's video is brought
to you by Venom.
Please give us money.
[music playing]
That looks so cool,
like a boiling black metal.
I'm amazed that
it's still bubbling.
Like, is it degassing?
It might actually just be
evaporating some of the liquids
that are down in the ink.
There are actually quite a few
chemicals involved in ball point ink,
and interestingly,
some of them
take almost two weeks
to evaporate out
after you write
on a piece of paper.
So that ink doesn't actually dry
completely for a couple of weeks.
I'm going to let
the pressure back in.
I don't think much
is going to happen.
Yep, didn't really
do anything.
Has a strong chemical smell.
Although,
it's going away quickly
so it might have just all
gotten carried off.
The inside of that cup is
about as covered in ink
as anything has ever been
covered in ink.
That's what happens when you
put it in a vacuum chamber.
What do you think is going
to happen if we freeze it?
Now, I've got a bowl
of liquid nitrogen.
And we're going to drip some ink
into it and see what it does.
I bet it freezes.
All right, let's pour some ink
in some liquid nitrogen.
I'm going to start
by just dripping a little bit
in out of our cup here
and the stuff is really thick
so it doesn't pour
super easily.
Ooh, and it gets even thicker
on contact with the liquid nitrogen.
Ooh, and then it just
starts to shatter.
It went in and started making
these fun little strands
and then after it was in there
for a few seconds,
it started kind of
exploding apart.
We got ink dust.
[music playing]
Some of the smaller
bits are now melting.
[music playing
We saw that this made
some really good bubbles
when we were using it
in the vacuum chamber.
I'm curious to see what happens
if we blow bubbles down into it.
[music playing]
Just look like a perfect
metallic spheres.
[music playing]
We've got some ink
in a metal bowl
and we're going to put it on our
little electric hot plate here,
and we're going to see
what happens to it.
[music playing]
There are some vapors
coming off of that ink.
Although to be fair,
I don't know 100% that's from the ink.
It might be from
the enamel on the bowl.
May not be a cooking bowl,
but it's white,
I wanted to use it because
it makes everything so nicely visible.
Now that it's hot,
it is a lot more liquid.
Before it was more
like the consistency of corn syrup
and now it's like the
consistency of cooking oil.
I'm going to try
and avoid breathing
those fumes
as much as possible.
I'm not a hundred
percent sure what they are,
but I bet I don't want it
in my lungs.
[music playing]
I would call that
a rolling boil at this point.
[music playing]
Now the consistency is
almost as thin as water.
Well after boiling off,
whatever it is that boils off,
it's the same color,
it's just hard
and dry and gross.
So don't boil ink,
nothing good happens.
Vacuumed, bubbled,
Frozen and boiled ballpoint pen ink.
It looks really cool,
it's got a cool color
and consistency and of course,
it's super potent like it stains your--
I am covered in ink marks
and I don't even know
where those are from
but I've had them
all over my face
and it's probably all
over my clothing as well.
I still have quite a bit of this stuff,
a little over a cup of it
that I haven't used up
or burned or anything like that.
So if you have any ideas
of things you'd like to see me do
with this ink let me know down
in the comments
and if we use your idea,
we just might send you 25 bucks.
Guys, that's not all,
we've got more for you to see
that box at the top will take you
directly to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next
and if you
are not yet a subscriber
hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you'll never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.